what is the best way to learn math for
people who might be at the beginning of
that journey I think that's a it's a
question that a lot of folks kind of ask
and think about and it doesn't even for
folks who are not really at the
beginning of their journey like there
might be actually is deep in their
career some type they've taken college
attain calculus and so on but still want
to sort of explore math well what would
be your advice instead of education and
all the ages your temptation will be to
spend more time like watching lectures
or reading
try to force yourself to do more
problems than you naturally would that's
a big one like the the focus time that
you're spending should be on like
solving specific problems and seek
entities that have well curated lists of
problems so go into like a textbook
almost in and the problems in the back
of a text and back of a chapter so if
you can take a little look through those
questions at the end of the chapter
before you read the chapter a lot of
them won't make sense some of them might
and those are those are the best ones to
think about a lot of them won't but just
you know take a quick look and then read
a little bit of the chapter and then
maybe take a look again and things like
that and don't consider yourself done
with the chapter until you've actually
worked through a couple exercises right
and and this is so hypocritical right
because I like put out videos that
pretty much never have associated
exercises I just view myself as a
different part of the ecosystem which
means I'm kind of admitting that you're
not really learning or at least this is
only a partial part of the learning
process if you're watching these videos
I think if someone's at the very
beginning like I do think Khan Academy
does a good job they have a pretty large
set of questions you can work through
just a very basic sort of just picking
picking out getting getting comfortable
with a very basic linear algebra
calculus have fun Khan Academy
programming is actually I think a great
like learn to program and like let the
way the math is motivated from that
angle push you through I know a lot of
people who didn't like math got into
programming in some way and that's what
turned them on to math maybe I'm biased
cuz like I live in the Bay Area so I'm
more likely to run into someone who has
that phenotype but I am willing to
speculate that that is a more
generalizable path so you yourself kind
of in creating the videos are using
program
to illuminate a concept but for yourself
as well so would you recommend somebody
try to make a sort of almost like try to
make videos like you do the exhalation
Larry what's the one thing I've heard
before I don't know if this is based on
any actual study this might be like a
total fictional anecdote of numbers but
it rings in the mind as being true you
remember about 10% of what you read you
remember about 20% of what you listen to
remember about 70% of what you actively
interact with in some way and then about
90% of what you teach this is a thing I
heard again those numbers might be
meaningless but they bring true don't
they right
I'm willing to say I learned the nine
times better than reading that might
even be a low ball yeah right so so
doing something to teach or to like
actively try to explain things is huge
for consolidating the knowledge
you